hey this is something that's more funny
than serious as many of you might
remember there's this conspiracy
theorist named Alex Jones who is kind of
in rough shape right now because his
programming violates the terms and
conditions of so many websites that it
got pushed off of a lot of those
platforms YouTube Vimeo iTunes Facebook
I don't even know the whole list at this
point so Alex Jones has been trying to
get attention in other ways and one of
those ways is he likes to go to
Washington DC when there's sort of like
a prominent congressional hearing and
try to get a bunch of attention either
by heckling the person who is speaking
who is going to be testifying or holding
impromptu press conferences sometimes he
brings Trump associate Roger stone with
him and he did this last week with
Google CEO sundar Pichai and I didn't
see this until last night and I cannot
believe that I missed it we're gonna
have a good time here that I can assure
you Alex Jones showed up in Washington
DC the day that sundar Pichai was
testifying and he tried to get attention
by first yelling at sundar Pichai from
like a hundred feet away but also by
doing one of these impromptu sort of
press conferences where he's just
ranting and raving and a lot of times
the press that are there don't even pay
attention so what's great about this
clip is not actually his confrontation
with sundar Pichai because sundar Pichai
doesn't seem to even really notice Alex
Jones first let's just look at like 20
seconds of that and you'll see how
miserably it failed you're engaged in
treason you've had Google executives lie
to Congress you're not censoring
conservatives sundar you will not
silence four people
there's sundar pichai right there yeah
so that part's actually really really
boring and it failed I mean it's just
really really dumb okay here's the gold
at some point during Alex Jones is
screaming sundar pichai makes it to the
door of the hearing room and he goes in
and he starts his testimony and that's
it as far as he's concerned when it
comes to hecklers Alex Jones kept
yelling and
causing a commotion and eventually
Capitol police told him listen you're
gonna have to stop yelling that this is
a congressional building and there's a
hearing going on and at some point
during this rant that Alex Jones is
going on this incredibly sweet looking
white-haired woman with a notepad must
be a journalist for some organization
she genuinely has no idea who Alex Jones
is although you'll see that she
recognizes his name she has no idea what
Alex Jones is doing and what he's trying
to achieve and she starts making it in
total honesty
so that Alex Jones has to explain to her
who he is and what he's doing there and
given Alex Jones's you know hilarious
alpha-male complex it is just delightful
to watch him try to explain to this
woman who just says whoa whoa whoa slow
down who are you and as Alex Jones
explains to her who she who he is she
just takes notes on her notepad
everything about this next clip is
amazing Google is officially in China
censoring and oppressing their people
yes the guy they silenced so they can
build strong men about me Google is
building censorship models using the
magic word isn't this the best pad wait
wait wait yeah no I hear your conspiracy
theories and all but who exactly are you
yeah and we do have a lot of younger
folks who watch the David Pakman show so
I think we may I even have to explain to
them who alex jones is because he's been
deep LAT for him for quite some time now
so then alex jones goes back to ranting
for a little while and then eventually
the same woman still confused still
taking notes on her notepad gets
involved again and this time she says
okay are you here on your for yourself
or are you representing some kind of
organization and again Alex Jones has to
explain to her what his presence there
is
about I am here as an American citizen
he has been deep lat formed as a
precedent to bring communist
chinese-style censorship to America and
and I am here to let Congress know that
Google and others have been lying to
Congress
I love the seriousness with which she
writes down everything he's saying as if
he's actually a serious person I mean
just amazingly entertaining and then one
other really funny thing at another
point during Alex Jones is ranting and
raving a woman who doesn't seem to even
know who Alex Jones is she starts
agreeing with Alex Jones on some point
that he makes which initially Alex Jones
seems to like until he realizes that
this random woman is completely taking
over his entire rant and then he
realizes he's losing control of the
dialogue just another just unbelievable
moment and that's what Chinese
government is doing what Google is doing
Chinese dollar try closing on Chinese
minorities Christians Buddhists
following dogs Muslims exactly
understand Mongolia media information
block it is not getting the information
out so what Google is doing today is
helping with helping the evil
suppressing people cultural genocide
going on is used to track everything
they're doing if that isn't evil if
Google helping put 2 million people in
the concentration right on record if
that isn't evil what the hell is that's
what I'm talking about so he had to take
it back over and realize that this woman
was just gonna go on for way too long
for him to continue his ranting so
everything going wrong and of course
police just saying to him listen
whatever you're saying you've got to
keep your voice down because this is a
professional building and there's a
hearing going on just classic everything
going wrong for
Alex Jones I love it today's program
sponsored in part by blinkers comm slash
Pakman I've talked about blinkers before
it's this awesome app that I've been
using for several months now and what it
does is take the best and most
critically acclaimed non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks that you can listen to in one
sitting you could listen to ten books in
an afternoon I know that many in our
audience want to expand their horizons
and learn more about all sorts of
different topics but we're mostly
limited by time to some degree I know
I'm not able to read all of the books
that I want simply because I've got
other stuff going on and that's why
blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand i think you are
going to like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month go to bli NK is t.com
slash PA k ma n